hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor remember to subscribe so that
you can get more free biology study
videos and hit that bell icon so you get
notifications also make sure you know
about the new thing that i'm doing and
that is providing you with free study
notes so if you find a tiny url link in
the description uh below the video
you'll be able to go to a folder again
this is free where you can have pdfs of
all of my board notes so that's the the
final board notes all filled in with all
the study notes added and you can study
from those so make sure you take
advantage of that now today we're going
to talk about aerolone mycins um with
some focus on this one
seven g0775 now what are arolomycins
this is a really really exciting
development in the field of antibiotic
research
basically aeromycins are a
relatively new class of antibiotics they
were isolated from
a soil sample
now i want to take a moment to make sure
you realize that soil is like the number
one place that we find antibiotics
something like 70 or 80 percent of the
antibiotics in use today um either
originated from soil microbes
or um are like synthetic
analogues that have been like tweaked in
a laboratory
based on natural compounds natural
antibiotics again found in soils being
produced by soil bacteria
to
compete with other soil bacteria
now natural aerolomycins meaning those
ones that were
isolated from the soil sample that are
made
naturally
by soil bacteria we evolved that
capability
these natural ones have a
narrow spectrum of activity
which is kind of too bad right when we
find a new antibiotic we really want it
to have a broad spectrum of activity if
you want to learn more about broad
versus narrow spectrum antibiotics
please see my video on that topic
now the natural aeromycins have this
narrow spectrum of activity where
they're able to inhibit
some
gram
positive bacteria
now if you do not know the difference
between gram-positive bacteria and
gram-negative bacteria please check out
my video on that topic it will explain
to you why we classify bacteria in these
two ways and how their cell walls are
different and once you've when you've
watched this one you'll realize that
gram positive bacteria
are
a little simpler for us to fight off a
little simpler for us to to design
antibiotics against than gram-negative
bacteria in fact we haven't had a new
antibiotic
approved for use in fighting
gram-negative bacterial infections in
about 50 years at this point
and the natural herlomycins they were
really only
active against some gram-positive
bacteria
but the reason these aerologins are so
exciting is because they have a really
novel i'm going to circle this
a really novel and then a star because
it's so exciting a really novel
mechanism basically of all of the
antibiotics that we have
they they tend to fall into certain
categories and there's just a few
categories you know
some will inhibit
protein synthesis some will inhibit dna
synthesis some will inhibit the cell
wall and there's a few other categories
too
but the aerolomycins were really
exciting because they have a brand new
mechanism of action that had never been
seen in any other antibiotic and
specifically that was inhibition of a
bacterial enzyme
called the type
one signal
peptidase
okay so the type 1 sigma peptidase
this is a great
target
for an antibiotic
what i mean by that is that the
bacterial signal peptidases they are
essential for bacterial survival they're
pretty different from human signal
peptidases
and then they are also relatively easy
to access and i go into a lot more
detail about those points
as well as what signal peptidases do
in my video on signal peptidases so if
you want to know what this thing does
for the bacteria and why it's such a
great target please check out that video
now
we've got this this new class of
antibiotics they have this novel
mechanism of action and they're
attracting a lot of research interest
specifically
in the search for novel antibiotics to
treat
antibiotic
resistant
bacterial infections
now if you've been studying biology for
a while i know you've heard of this i
know you've heard of the increase in
antibiotic resistance particularly among
human pathogens
we have so many pathogens now that are
resistant to so many of our antibiotics
that frankly it's becoming scary
uh this has been called the antibiotic
resistance apocalypse or the antibiotic
apocalypse
by scientists and by doctors because
we're having fewer and fewer antibiotics
that work against human pathogens now
because so many of these pathogens are
becoming resistant
now i have a great video on antibiotic
resistant bacteria that goes through
how this antibiotic resistance happens
and also gives you a lot of examples
of different antibiotic resistant
bacteria
so make sure you go check that one out
but in particular with aerolomycins as
they've been studied
um we have found that there are four
different classes of aerolomycins
these are
aerolomycins
um a b
c
and to d so those are the four classes a
b c and d
and they have activity mainly against
staphylococcus and streptococcus species
one example is actinocarbicen this is an
aerolomycin d so it's in that fourth
group parallelon d and it actually is
able to inhibit
mrsa
now mrsa is methicillin-resistant
staphylococcus aureus and it is causing
big problems for our communities and for
our hospitals you can learn more about
mrsa in this antibiotic resistant
bacteria video
now another one that is really exciting
i am going to put a big star by it is
g0775
now let's talk about what this is all of
this over here is about g0775 what it is
how it works why it's important so
this is
a
synthetic
aerolomycin analog what does that mean
that means it's not just a natural one
that was pulled from soil bacteria
samples
it's actually
synthetics was made in a lab
by research scientists and it's an
aeromycin analog that means that they
took basically the the backbone of the
natural aerodynamics of which there are
a few
and they tweaked this and they tweaked
that and they changed this functional
group and they added another functional
functional group and they changed this
bond and they just made
various changes but all kind of
using that that backbone that comes from
those natural
aerologs and antibiotics
so this was developed by a
pharmaceutical company called genentech
and they actually studied
something like 1700 i think is the
number that they they put out
1700 approximately synthetic aerobics
and analogs 1700
they just made all kinds of changes in
these different analogs
and tested each of these hundreds of
analogs to see which ones would be the
most potent and in the end this g0775
was kind of the best of the bunch
and it is ten thousand times to a
hundred thousand times
more
potent
more potent than the natural aeromycins
so they tweaked this and they tweaked
that and they made something that's ten
thousand or a hundred thousand times
better than these various natural
heralomycins
specifically this
g0775 has been manipulated by
researchers to strongly inhibit
what which type do you think gram
positive or brand negative remember
the gram positive is what it had some
narrow activity against already that the
natural erroneous but
g0775 strongly inhibits gram
negative bacteria and again this is a
big deal because we're negative bacteria
because of their particular their
particular cell wall
characteristics again check out this
video of mine if you want to know more
about that but because of their
particular characteristics in their in
their cell wall they are so much more
difficult
for us
to
target
so to have this new analog that can
strongly inhibit their negative bacteria
is so exciting it's really such a big
deal
this could you know when i stress could
become the first new antibiotics
approved to fight for negative bacterial
infections in that's right
50 years like in my entire lifetime
there's not been a new antibiotic
approved to fight gram-negative bacteria
and this could be the first in so long
it can even kill what we call
multi
drug
resistant
whoops got an extra s on there hang on
multi drug resistant we use the
abbreviation mdr multi-drug resistant
gram-negative bacteria and even
pan
resistant
gram-negative bacteria
now a couple of things i want to explain
here pan resistant
means
a bacterium like a strain of bacteria
that is resistant to all
known
antibiotics or at least all that all
antibiotics that are in clinical use
okay
and these pan resistant bacteria they
exist they exist already and frankly
it's terrifying
these are bacteria that are resistant to
every antibiotic that doctors have
available to prescribe
and so to have a new inhibitor
that can
kill
bacteria that are resistant to multiple
drugs or resistant to all antibiotics
that we've got that's a big deal now i
do want to stress this right here in
vitro
okay
in vitro means in a test tube so this
g0775
is able to kill multi-drug resistant and
pan-resistant gram-magnetic bacteria in
vitro in a test tube
if it has been tested in an actual human
being who is infected by one of these
really really scary superbugs then i'm
not aware of that maybe it has been
maybe not i couldn't find any
information about that
um let's talk about now about how okay
how
is it so good
you know how is it so good that it's ten
thousand to a hundred thousand times
more potent than the natural ones found
in the soil samples
well that's because with all of those
different tweaks made by the scientists
at the pharmaceutical company
it is now g zero seven seven five is
able to do something that natural
aerobics don't do and that is that it
forms a covalent
bond with the target
and so this increases its binding
strength and the permanence of the
binding remember that what this
synthetic analog is going to do is it's
going to bind
to
i believe it's the active site of the
signal peptidase
and by binding there that prevents the
signal peptidase from doing what it
would normally do and what it would
normally do again i described that in
this video
what it would normally do is
essential for the bacteria to survive
and so when it's being inhibited
by an aeromycin particularly one that
can form a covalent bond in the active
site that means that that signal
peptidase i mean it's it's out it can't
do anything it can't do its essential
function if this antibiotic is
bonded with a covalent bond to its
active site that's how it works um
and so now you know for me personally
the big question is what's going on now
all this information
um was basically put out and made a big
splash and i think it was 2018 and i
haven't heard anything since then um i
did a quick google search to kind of see
if this is like in clinical trials or
something at this point um and i
couldn't really find uh i really
couldn't find any information so that's
why i've got all these question marks
right here i would love to know what's
going on with
g0775 with other aerologins and other
aerobics and analogs
i really really hope that this will
give us another weapon in our arsenal to
be able to fight these really scary
multi-drug resistant bacteria and pan
resistant bacteria
so make sure you get the free study
notes by looking at the tiny url in the
description below
and check out some of my other videos
and i wish you good luck studying for
biology and thank you for watching
biology professor please remember to
subscribe thanks guys bye